This is Jocko podcast number
one 47 with Echo Charles and me,
Jocko Willink. Good
Evening Echo. Good evening.
It's been a little while since we've done
some Q and a so we'll do some Q and. A.
Cool.
Thanks to everyone for the questions
that you have submitted to the podcast,
just a reminder of what's the
best way to submit a question.
The best way is Twitter
or Facebook and yeah,
those are the best of your Facebook.
My Facebook or my Twitter.
I don't, the Instagram messages
are just out of control.
There's too many of them and I appreciate
it, but I can't get a grip on them.
So Twitter and and people would,
if it's a long question,
well the right three Twitter statements.
If it's longer than you
know that many characters,
it's probably then go to Facebook. If
this is like really a long, long thing,
then just go to Facebook and send
me the message. What is that called?
A Facebook message? Instant
Messenger. Direct message.
I think DM is like a con when Your
Messenger on Facebook is what I get.
I deal again, I apologize. I don't
get to respond to all of them.
Sometimes I just try and get somebody
a little like the, hey, I read it. Hey,
thanks. Uh, you know, you
know what to do. Right.
A lot of times people, they're just asking
me because they want to get confirmed.
Yeah, yeah. Hey, do you think I've,
I'm having problems with this
girl when she cheated on me,
but I don't know if I should leave or
not. It's like, you know what to do bro.
You know what to do. So
speaking, of course, thanks
for everyone for the questions.
And,
and that being said,
I still look at just about
everything that comes in. Sometimes.
Sometimes they get a little bit lost,
but I look at everything that comes in.
Sometimes people, if you're
listening, if you send me a question,
some people would ask
me a question that I've,
I've literally been asked
and we've answered on the
podcast three or four times.
So keep listening to the podcast
because if I don't say anything,
most likely it's because
I've answered that over.
I've answered it two or three times
or you can deduce what to do just from
listening to the podcast. You'll figure it
out. Oh, I need to go get after it. Like
you know,
went into Elko.
I think that it might be a
good idea to have let go. What?
Equity Cough frequently
ass. Yeah, I know. I know.
We do need to do that.
Yeah. So let's do it.
Check first question.
We said that for like two years.
Yeah, I did. Right when I said that
I was like, should I think? Yeah,
that'd be no 10 Debbie put together
like a whole thing on that maybe.
Yeah she did. So we could probably dig
that up and actually put it to use,
which would be smart. Yes sir. I
believe. I believe the same thing.
First question,
do you have any thoughts on what dis
disciplines someone can use to improve
their decision making skills as a leader?
Not only in keeping clarity of thought
during high pressured situations and
environments, but also in making the
correct decisions when it is vital. Okay,
so we've talked about this last week.
You have to learn to detach.
And how do you learn to detach?
You've learned it.
Hatch by putting yourself in stressful
situations and then observing how you
react. So good stretch, stressful
situations to put yourself in. Well,
what makes you stressed? One thing
that will make everyone's stressed,
especially when they first start,
is start with Jujitsu. That's gonna,
that's gonna put you in stressful
environments. Look at sports.
What are you going to do? You know, put
yourself in stressful positions in sports.
What else makes you stress?
Public speaking, right?
Public speaking makes some people really
stressed out and start doing it more.
What about competition
shooting where you've got a,
or hunting where you've got
to do something in a stressful
environment or archer,
you know, I started started archery
recently. You did? Oh yeah. Yeah.
And so that's one of those things
where you've got to learn to detach.
You gotta learn to pay attention
to things that are going on.
If you're all caught up in the moment,
then you're going to miss it.
So that's number one.
If you want to learn to deal with stress,
put yourself in stressful situations
that are under some kind of control.
You know,
even something like a paint ball,
you know we do gigs and echelon front
where we put people through what we call
FTX is where you go out
and you're going to fire.
We usually use air soft
because it's a little bit more,
it's a little easier to work with.
But actually what we started using now
is we've got these high end laser tag
guns and so that's, that's what we
use and they are super effective.
They're there, they're awesome.
They're awesome training tools.
LikeW if we would have had them,
if we would've,
if they would've existed
when I was in the seal teams,
I would have used them then
because they're that good.
So we use those and we put people in
stressful situations. Go hit this target.
There's bad guys, there's, you
know, people are going to get shot.
There's people yelling.
Put yourself in stressful,
stressful situations and learn to detach.
Put yourself in stressful situations with
the purpose of learning to detach and
stepping back mentally to figure out
what's going on. Okay, that's first part.
Next part is how do we make good
decisions? Well, number one,
making correct decisions. You've got to
study, you got to know and understand.
You've got to know the background,
you've got to know the historical
outcomes of equivalent type decisions that
have happened in the past,
similar situations and if you know the
history and you know the background,
then you can use those to assess
the current situation you're in.
And then once you assess the
decisions that you can make,
assess the possible actions
that you can take Admin,
assess the outcomes that
those decisions will have,
those actions will have.
And when you're doing that,
you also have to assess the
possibilities of inaction.
So a lot of times people forget that one,
they don't know.
They don't know if they should do a or B.
What they forget is there's also,
what if I don't do either?
What's going to happen?
Sometimes not doing either as good.
Most that were a lot of times not doing
either is bad. So you've got a or B,
what should you do?
Maybe sometimes you got to pick a or B.
Sometimes occasionally it's better not
to do anything and you wait and let the
situation develop a little bit more.
What?
So the point of this is whatever you can
know beforehand, you know, you learn,
you study, you understand, you know
the standard operating procedures,
you know what various variations have
been made on the standard operating
procedures. And that's how you
go forward and you execute.
Now the thing that you have to remember
is that you can't know everything
beforehand,
which is why it goes back to study and
practice detaching and making decisions.
So, so now let me dig into
detaching a little bit.
Let's actually break that down.
Maybe some mechanical steps that
you can use. Number one, step back.
Like literally physically take a step
back from the situation that you're in and
move your head and look around.
So when we used to shoot,
they would teach us to scan, like you
would have to physically move your head.
And what that is,
is a mental reminder that you need to
look around and assess what's happening.
So once you've taken a step off the line,
whether that's taken a step back from
the table and you're in a meeting,
if you're a, if you're a firefighter
and there's a fire happening,
take a step back so you can see the
bigger picture. If you're in a cop and,
and there's a shootout happening,
where can you go to step back and get
some cover and look around and see what's
actually happening? If you're in a, if
you're in a conversation with someone,
stop talking. If there's an
argument going on, stop talking.
Take a step back and actually listen to
all the other elements that are shouting
and yelling at each other. If there's a
decision that needs to needs to be made,
I don't on a planning situation,
step back from the plan.
Don't just take a step back from it.
Look at it more broadly.
So that's step number one is to step back.
Number two,
then you're gonna come up with,
hey,
one of the possible decisions that I can
make. I could go this way. I B Abcd, ABCD.
I can do any one of these things.
Keep an open mind.
This is the problem. Some people have
as they come up with two decisions,
three decisions,
and they don't think about anything else,
so you kind of have to like repeatedly
detach. You kind of have to stay detached.
That's why it's good.
You throw out an idea,
like if we're planning for something and
I come up with three ideas, I say, echo,
what do you think of these? I give
them to you. Then I stepped back again.
I keep my mind open,
so that's why the more you can
get your subordinates to plan,
the better off you're going to be.
The more you can get the people below
you in the chain of command to come up
with an idea or come up with the ideas,
the better off we're going to be because
you're not embroiled in it. You're,
you're defacto detached because you're
letting them run with it. Then, okay.
Once you look at your decisions and
you've got to look at what the possible
outcomes are,
what are the possible things
that can happen is this could,
how bad could this go?
Risk versus reward.
You've got to weigh those things out
and you got to do it fairly quickly and
again,
you've got to,
you got to figure out what's the result
or possible outcome for inaction.
And then you just weigh out these various
options that you've created and you
figure which one, which outcome has the
most, which one makes the most sense?
That's that's what's good.
And like I said,
inaction is some people like any
action is better than no action,
not always true,
not always true.
Sometimes you can learn more by letting
things develop and letting things reveal
what the status is. So that does make
sense. And sometimes you do hold off.
If if you, if you can see that a
problem is getting worse though,
we'll then we've got to do
something then generally, okay,
let's make some kind of a
decision very quickly. Now,
one of the most important
things to remember,
and there's a little dichotomy to this,
is that you don't always
have to make giant decisions.
You don't always have to
make the, all the, the,
the all powerful decision of might,
you know, it's like, do we go or do we
not go? You don't always have to say,
we go. Sometimes you can go, well, let's
push a little further. Let's, let's move.
Let's move a little bit further
before we make that decision. Or, Hey,
let's stay where we are
and see if it develops,
or let's back up a little bit
and keep watching. So instead of,
we go and we don't go,
there's actually a bunch of different
decisions that you can make besides,
we can go or don't go. There's a building,
there's a bad guy in it. Let's go.
Or let's not go. No, actually, let's put
eyes on the target for a little while.
Let's, let's call and see if
there's any other intelligence.
Let's put an aircraft overhead. There's
all kinds of decisions that you can make.
Let's push a little bit closer.
Let's stage, let's monitor.
So there's all kinds of decisions
that you can make that allow the,
the situation to develop further and
maybe reveal the proper decision to you in
the long run.
So the mice,
my fear of saying that is
that people get paralyzed.
Where does it analyze the parallel
and parallel analysis paralysis.
That's my fear about saying that because
the dichotomy is you can sit around and
analyze and figure out and look at
something for over for forever while the
situation changes and now you lose.
So yes,
you don't have to make giant decisions,
but at the same time you gotta be
decisive. There's a dichotomy. I'm sorry.
I'm sorry. Leadership is not easy.
Wrote a whole book about it. Dichotomy.
Leadership. Why? Cause that's
what happens. So there you go.
That's my assessment of how you can
improve your decision making skills.
Experience goes a long way.
Yeah.
It's one of those deals kind of
when you were talking about the,
the results versus the,
the, the method, right?
Decision making thumb.
Sometimes like the result actually both
method and results kind of the value
isn't even in the results.
It's like you having getting that
experience going through it, you know,
it'll improve your decision. Sure, sure.
Yeah. Anytime you can be in a situation
where you're making decisions and getting
experience out or you're going
to get better at it. Yeah.
Kind of the value in role
playing that is a value.
That's why we do a lot of role playing
in echelon for like a little thing and
people might think, oh that, how does that
work? Come and get it. Totally get it.
I watch people all the time,
it totally improve as leaders because put
them through a role play scenario as a
leader where they're going up against a
combative subordinate or a subordinate
that's lazy or I subordinates angry or
a subordinate that that wants to leave.
Like you put it,
you put a person in role playing in
those situations over and over again and
they get so much better.
Three iterations,
three iterations and people
are exponentially better
at handling situations.
Yeah. Cause it's like some, I
mean most of the time anyway,
it's just a matter of them
like never seen it before.
And then in the during game time it's
Kinda like you got to make the decision
super fast that you can't analyze
from the role playing situation.
You can analyze, you can do whatever and
then t and then learn it. No a great,
I actually should have brought that up.
That's a great point.
Is another way that you can get better
at making decisions by roleplay for sure.
Give yourself the options.
Put, get put yourself,
set yourself up a pressure situation and
have people role play it out with you
of what you're going to do. Yeah,
so it's kind of like like mock,
that's basically what it is.
It is mock experience.
That's basically what seal training,
well not the basic seal training
but the seal training that I ran,
that's basically what it was. We're
going to have people act like bad guys.
You're going to make decisions all day
long. That's a roleplay. Get some. Yeah
and again going back to like just seeing
it once right is seen at one time is
the D is way bigger difference than then.
I mean compared with never seen
it all versus seen at once.
The difference between that is way bigger
than seeing it like twice versus once
you know, if you seen it once, it's Kinda
like, okay, now I know. Yeah, it's, yeah.
It's like night and day.
It's night and day.
The difference between
knowledge and like, no, no, no.
Knowledge is crazy. If we see
that over and over and over again,
like an Indiana Jones and the last
crusade. You ever seen that one?
I'm pretty sure. Wait,
how old is that one?
Like I saw the all like that
series when Connor was a kid.
I think I seen it. So at the end,
and they go through things, right?
That they're like these booby traps.
Right, and he'd get the holy grail.
That's what they're doing.
Oh,
that I've seen this one because everyone
in the guy's face melts, right? No,
that's great. It's the last song
when they opened the Ark. Oh,
you got to shut your eyes. Yeah.
That's old school anyway. No, this one,
they have to go through these,
like these tests or whatever.
They're their booby traps
to get to the holy grail.
And one of them was you have to kneel.
Only the penitent man will pass. That's
what it says. And the grail diary,
which is Indiana Jones Dad's
diary that took all the notes.
And so he's like, Oh, you've
got to interpret that. Right.
So they had all these people,
there were bad guys there too.
So they just send someone in there
and then the guide go in and
his head gets chopped off.
So you go in there, you know, hey that
blade is going to come chop off my head.
Cause I seen that one guy
get his head chopped off.
I'm just gonna duck just one time.
It's,
I got to know the blade's going to
come out dunk. Thanks Indy. Granted,
granted there was more booby traps and
you kinda got to refer to the grill diary
for the answers subject to
interpretation by the way. But same deal.
He see the point though, right? If
you walk through a hallway, get it,
then you see the guy get his
head chopped off, you know. Okay,
I better duck down your best
doc. Yeah. Yup. I get it.
Thank you. One time. One time.
That's all it takes. Anyway, next
question. How do you practice normal fee?
So same.
And the reason that group these two
questions together is because there's a
little, there's some similarities there.
You know, how do you practice normal face,
which is a legitimate skill
by the way. Yes sir. It's,
oh, it's funny. Little game.
If you haven't heard of what you do is,
I used to do this for my kids.
I put line them up and if they made any
expression whatsoever besides just a
normal plain face,
I'd hit him in the head with a the inside
cardboard roll up of a wrapping paper.
So there's, there's the game and it's
a lot of fun. We'd have fun doing it.
Everyone would laugh.
Well it's also useful in his adult to
do be able to not show your emotions.
So how do you do it?
Same thing.
Put yourself in stressful situations
and you know, a good one is Jujitsu.
Jujitsu. If you can just like act normal,
even when someone's just crushing you,
then that's a positive thing. It's like,
you know, sometimes you and I are rolling.
Yes. And you'll be like, oh,
I felt a sense of urgency is
that's when I lose normal.
It's failure to keep normal face a little
bit scrambled because you're going to
pass or something like that and then you,
then you feel all good because you made
me react, you broke my normal face.
So yes,
that's good.
I would say the thing about
normal faces practice it all time.
You know where you practice it,
you practice it like when you're driving.
I mean I can't do this anymore because
when we started this podcast I would get
questions all the time about road rage.
How do you prevent road rage?
How do you permit roadmap?
I think everyone's so in the game
now that there they figured it out,
but that's a good anytime where
there's something bad happening,
like something annoying.
Something like the line,
the line at the DMV, the line,
wherever and you just just,
just keep normal face and
just act like whatever.
Detach and he'll just act normal in
Jujitsu when you're in between rounds.
Don't act tired. Yeah.
That's like one of my,
I try and maintain that rule all the time.
You
taught me that, oh, I don't even
know if you meant to teach me that.
And I told this story before but I would
roll up, you're going to hear it again.
We'd roll and I be tired of whatever
after rolling with you. And then you know,
and people do this all the time and
it sticks. It's like a red flag to me.
Not a red flag warning of
it just sticks out a lot.
When people do this after
the round, they'll just flop
on their back and be like,
you know, like breathing all hard
kind. Just you know, indicating
that, Whoa, that was a tiring
round. Right? Yeah. You
need to have tire grounds,
get it kind of thing.
And then this is the message that you
conveyed to me through your actions.
You didn't tell me this,
so I wrote a few and I do that or
something along those lines. Right.
And you like stand up,
not breathing through your mouth.
I remember that you're just like,
you know like mouth closed and then you
were looking at me almost like you're
disappointed in me. Came back. Yes.
I realize you probably were and you said
you look a little tired and then you
just walked away.
Like almost like that was the bad part.
The the part that I looked tired that that
was like the bad part you didn't like.
And I was like from literally from
then on I'd act like I wasn't tired in
between. Even if I was tired, I've tried
to act like I'm not tired actively.
That's so important. It's
important in life. Yeah. You know,
it's important as a leader it's more
way more important as a leader than
anything else when you
start to break things. Well,
I don't know if you have any examples,
but like I think of times in my life where
I would see my leaders start to break
and just think like how horrible that
is for the rest of the team and I'd be
looking at a leader that was
breaking. I'd be like, man,
you aren't letting everyone down
and you're not going to do it to me.
I'm going to, you know what? Actually
this is an opportunity for me.
If you're looking weak, I'm not going
to get all aggressive, but I'm going to,
I'm going to make sure that people aren't
going to follow that attitude because
that is going to hurt us
all. Yeah, so as a leader,
normal faces even more important.
I'm not saying you never showed
emotions at this dichotomy.
I'm not saying never show emotions as
a leader because you absolutely do show
emotions as a leader,
but you make sure that they're controlled.
You make sure they're not emotion,
negative emotions.
So am I saying to not
be yourself? Yes, I am.
Because if your self is being a week a
week loser and you're in charge of a team
and you show everyone that you're wrong,
no, you need to stifle those emotions,
which we've talked about before. You
just stifle those. You need to act.
You need to act like, hey,
we're going to make this happen.
This doesn't mean lie to them. This
isn't like a, hey, the boat's sinking,
but don't worry, we're, it's
going to be okay. No. Hey,
guess what? Boats sinking. No,
we're going to do,
we're going to break out.
A life jacket is going to form into pool.
We're going to grab whatever
we can off this pastor.
We're going to make sure we get, you know
what I mean? As opposed to boat sinking,
right? Yeah, it's true. So you lead check.
So if, um, what like when your
kid falls down, right? Yeah,
totally. Totally. Like, oh my gosh.
Are you okay? Yeah, no negative.
Yeah. Wait. Oh, how's
it? I was at the park.
My son two climbs up high on this thing.
It's like,
it's slanted a jungle gym kind of thing.
It's just slant it.
It's like pretty high where it's not like
so high that he shouldn't be up there.
It's not that,
but it's,
it's high where you got to keep
an eye on that thing right there.
And sure enough,
he takes a step or whatever and just
straight up falls to the ground and the
ground is ah, the ground was like a
bunch of this weird hey kind of stuff.
So it's, it wasn't like concrete,
put it that way, but he fell down,
pull on and the kind, you know, looking
at other parents who are looking at it.
My wife is sitting right next to me.
We've kind of far away me,
literally grabbed her like, don't run
over there. And um, my daughter was there,
she's super caring too, so I'm like,
ah, I should have grabbed her too.
But she's far away anyway, so he
falls down. Of course it doesn't cry.
He's more like surprised and stun and
looking around almost with the look on his
face. Like, how should I react to him
now? That's exactly what he's doing. Yeah.
And then, yeah, it's all good. I mean,
yeah, my kids would take a digger,
I'd start laughing you don't like,
oh, that was awesome. Yeah, it makes
sense. And they're like, really? Yeah,
that was awesome. We got little
Skinner. Nice. Look, you're bleeding.
That's going to leave a cool scar. You're
awesome. Welcome to the club. Yeah,
that's a good one. Like so like that's
awesome kind of thing. I'll be like, oh,
I stand up strong, hurry up, hurry up.
Like kind of like you got to beat it and
like show me how strong you are kind of
thing. Oh, I did that the
other day nonetheless. Yeah,
so he got up and he didn't cry.
Of course he goes to high
asphalt to injury. He landed
correctly. How many feet?
It was taller than I stand, so,
so we're talking to seven feet.
Seven, six, six. Yeah. Over over bigger.
Yeah, it was. It was
solid, but he landed good.
Like if you would have landed on his head,
that's an injury straight up.
But he felt like good, which is
lucky. But yeah, nonetheless. So yeah,
the point is if I were to who it like
ran over there, something like this,
it would have jammed him up. Oh yeah.
Isn't that why the airline pilots,
when you get turbulence,
they're like, hey everybody,
just go ahead and buckle your seat belts.
We're,
we might feel a little bit more that you
know, instead of, hey guys, we're good.
Yeah, I very much appreciate that when
we do that, by the way. All right,
next question.
Next question.
I tell the team we need this
done by 3:00 PM they say got it,
we'll have it done by 3:00 PM but they
don't deliver on time and tell me,
well we didn't know we needed it done
by 3:00 PM how do I take ownership of
this? Yeah, this is it.
This seems like a tough question,
right?
But it's actually not that tough of a
question because what you think is like,
well they said they were going to get
done then they didn't get it done.
Then how could that be my fault?
Right.
And maybe that's not how
the question is meant,
but that's the way I'm interpreting
it for the purpose of this answer.
True cause maybe you just meant like,
hey, how do I take ownership of this?
And if that's the way he meant it,
fine. The answer is the same actually.
So what happens is if,
if it happens,
what happens is if that
happens with your team,
then you take ownership of it by
recognizing that you did not communicate
effectively.
Because if your team
isn't doing what it is you need them
to do, that is actually your fault.
As the team leader,
they either didn't understand
how important it was or
they didn't understand how
solid that deadline was
or they didn't understand that when you
said this thing needs to be completed by
three o'clock that you meant completed
by three o'clock maybe it's cause you
usually say,
hey,
we need this done tomorrow at two and
you give him slack and they just kind of
take advantage of it, blah,
blah, blah. Then you know,
if you want to take ownership of it,
maybe you didn't follow up enough, right?
Maybe you trusted them too much.
Whose fault is it if you trusted
him so much that you just let them,
you showed up at two 59 is it done?
Well, no, we didn't think it was due.
Like we didn't know you needed an action.
So whose fault is that? It's your fault.
You trusted them too much, maybe you
gave them too much leeway, right?
Maybe you give them too much leeway, too
much decentralized command, dichotomy,
leadership. Maybe you went too far with
decentralized command. You said, hey,
if get this done by three o'clock
for out however you want to do it,
I'll be back at two 59
and you roll out and that's not done.
So what do you do?
You come back at three o'clock
it's not done. Did is your fault?
Do you take ownership of it? You say
to your team, look, hey, okay, so how,
how do you take ownership of
it? Cool. You fixed the problem.
How do you fix the problem in
this case? Well, guess what?
Next time I tell you something is not
done at three o'clock I'm going to check
in with you.
I'm gonna check in with you a few times.
Here's the progress that we want to make.
I don't want you to be here by this point.
I want you to be here by this point.
I want you to be here.
That by this point.
And that puts us on track to finish
well ahead of three o'clock. Yeah.
So let's make it happen. Are you going
to micromanage a little bit more? Yes,
you are. They missed a deadline.
You're not allowed to miss deadlines.
Not Allowed to miss deadlines. Do I
micromanage you? Echo Charles? No.
Have you ever missed a deadline? No. Well,
there's been some hot gas that didn't come
out on time, right? Yeah. I guess the,
depending on the lunch
meat, I guess. But yeah,
there's been some podcasts that
didn't come out on time. Yes.
And I would send you a text like,
hey,
just wondering if you knew about a
podcast that was supposed to come out five
hours ago that happened one
time. Well, no. Two things.
I think it's happened two
times. One of them. Yeah.
So you don't warrant
micromanagement cause you,
we've done 147 podcasts and you've
had two that weren't out on time.
Do I need to micromanage?
You know, I don't. Don't need
to because we're all good.
The podcast. Hey, occasionally the
times that they didn't come out,
one of them was like straight up
operator error where you were like,
I didn't press the button publish
or something really lame like that.
The other time it was like major
technical difficulty. We got a problem,
it's going to be a couple of days.
Then there was another time.
What was the other time when we went
to Maine last year and what happened?
We just got there.
The on the night that I was supposed to
publish in my mind was just distracted
by the new, I had lost my camera. It
was a crazy time for everybody. And uh,
you know, the next morning
you still um, you know,
graciously posted a picture of me sleeping
on the plane by the way,
and said movie.
So working to Ecuador
publish a podcast publicly,
which is complete violation
by the way. Take a picture
of me sleeping. A fun. Yeah.
Yeah,
it was,
it was actually completely warranted
because it really captured like what it
felt like.
I just totally spaced it out.
So my point is you get stuff done on time.
You have a good track record there.
No need for micromanagement. If you
were, if you were hitting a lower number,
if every, you know, once every
once a month, it wasn't on time,
you'd be hearing about it
all the time. For me, I'd be
like, Hey, we good tomorrow.
We good?
Yeah,
I'd be checking in with you until you
got so mad at me following up with you.
You would just be like,
hey,
I got this and you would never miss
it again because you didn't want to be
bothered. Right. So for this one, again,
it's important to remember that
with the idea of extreme ownership,
it's not just like, oh well
I'll say this is my fault. No.
When you're in charge of a
team and something goes wrong,
it actually is your fault.
It actually is your fault.
And that's all there is to it.
Maybe there's some people you
need to fire because they are the,
they're at fault for this
mistake happening and you've
let it go too long and
you didn't get rid of him. That's your
fault. But it actually is your fault.
How do you take on or how do you take
ownership of it? You fix the problem.
Maybe you got to,
in this particular case,
maybe you've got to step up
the micromanagement. That's,
that's the way it works.
Yeah,
it makes sense also to the W and I'm
speaking from a perspective of someone who
could very well easily space out this
project by 3:00 PM by the way, that's,
that's potentially me. But this is,
this is when it can't happen. Um,
where let's say I get a list of like two
or three things, whatever I gotta do,
right? Like, Hey, we, you
know, we want this or whatever.
And then let's say it's not necessarily
by 3:00 PM let's say it's like by next
week,
Friday.
So I got a week and a half to do these
three things and then the next day
there's like another list of two things.
Then the next day after that one
things is, hey, you know what?
This is the priority. Three days
later after Lisbon establish, hey,
this is the priority. Get this done first.
Then you got one more thing. All right,
so this thing that I said, yeah, got it.
I'll have it done by Friday kind of thing.
She sorta get shuffled in
forgotten, you know, like forgotten.
So maybe I didn't organize it or what's
your point in saying this is putting
yourself on report? Are you saying
that you need to make a list?
Are you just saying you need to write
things down? People that miss things,
you know you do your write them down.
I used to make little boxes.
I'll show you some of the checklists.
You come to my house,
I'll show you checklists. I used to
make their, I mean we're psycho OCD,
little checklists, little boxes next
to like I would be going on a trip.
I would make a little box socks,
t shirts,
everything. Every single thing I
was taken I would have on a list.
I still got those lists.
I got bit deployments from the,
the nineties of what I took on deployment.
It was pretty legit right there.
Little boxes,
little boxes in the 90s they were written
down on paper in the two thousands I
got the computer. I print those
things out. Note App. So, hey,
you haven't,
you will have problems if you personally
are telling me that you have a problem,
you've got to write something
down. Yeah. So yeah,
and obviously you know mean
you're different. I don't
have those kinds of notes,
but what I'm saying is uh,
yeah,
like that could be your methodology of
your micro quote unquote micromanagement
style for things like this. Just make
sure they got it kind of thing like yeah,
for sure. Things, I'm thinking about fact
there could, you can, you can give lists.
I normally wouldn't have to do this,
but sometimes there's been a couple times
in my life and career where I'd have
to give people a list like, hey, I
hate the boxes for them. Like, Hey,
here's what you got to get done today.
Make sure we understand each other.
I would only do that if they
drop the ball a couple times.
Like all they didn't get this done
that he'd get that done. Okay.
Guess what I need to write down and make
sure it happens. Yeah. So yeah. And again,
it's not like, Eh, I'm not saying it's
not my fault cause you give me too much.
I'm not saying that. I'm saying like
not everyone, me, I'm talking about me.
Not everyone's as organized as maybe you,
you know,
so they're going to need
some micromanagement in this
particular way. You know?
Maybe cause maybe that's it.
I mean I think the tone here,
the question could be me
totally could be made mystery,
but it kind of seems like, hey, they
said they got it and they didn't get it.
What more do you want from me?
Kind of thing. You know the banker.
That's a good way of putting it and then
I just gave the list of what more you
can do. Yeah, exactly. You can spell
it out for him. You can micromanage,
you can check and do checkins with
them. Do all those things. Yeah.
Very good.
Next question.
The question you must have strong
feelings about current events and politics
generally given your experience yet
you remain silent on this issue.
Why?
To appeal to a larger audience or the
soldier's mentality of not criticizing the
commander in chief? Is that, why
do I have strong feelings on
current events and politics?
Uh, sure I do, but
they're more broad.
So I have very strong broad feelings
on current events and politics.
I am a patriotic person.
I believe very strongly in
individual freedoms of human beings.
I believe in having a
very strong military,
I believe in having a small government.
So I have strong feelings
about those things. However,
I don't have strong feelings about the
nonsense and micro dramas that are on the
24 hour news cycle that are
just content and social media.
Just constant things. I know we
talked about this a lot, last podcast,
things that don't matter.
So much of the current events don't
really matter in the big picture to me or
even to the country.
And you know,
I was uh,
on Ben Shapiro show and you know, he
was, I basically said, look, look,
like be overall Americans have sort
of the same goals. And he said,
I don't know if I believe
that. And I said, well,
I work with all kinds of companies
with people all over the country,
and the people that buy a guy
like Ben Shapiro, here's from,
he's just,
he's just bombarded by the
extremes on both sides,
24 hours a day.
I don't want to be in that position of
getting bombarded by these extremes 24
hours a day. I said, Ben, you're right.
There are some people in the country that
believe the far left or the far right.
I said,
most people are concerned about their
life and doing a good job and you know,
building their business or do you know,
by paying down their mortgage,
that's what they're concerned about.
And so they're not like freaking out
about the little every little micro drama
that gets unleashed into the press
and social media every single day.
And so, so why do I not join into that?
Cause I don't want to join into that.
And also I don't want to make a podcast.
I don't want to spend all my time making
a podcast that's, that's out of date.
The day it comes out like I don't want,
I don't want to invest my time in that.
I don't want to, and guess
what? There's, there's literally
giant multibillion dollar news media
outlets and guess what they do?
That's what they do all day.
They make up story about this thing and
that thing and this thing where I can't
react fast enough.
It's just dumb.
So if we were to be talking
about current events,
then by the time the podcast comes out,
the parent event has been over,
some people are listening to this podcast
and it's, it's, it's 2022 right now.
Right now.
Some someone is listening to this
podcast right now and it's 2022 no,
there's, there's no topic of current
events that we could talk about. Oh,
barely any that actually impact
what's happening four years from now.
People, I meet people every day now I
meet people that, that say, Hey, oh man,
I've been listening to
podcasts. I'm on 28. Um, that's,
that's two years ago, right?
That's two years ago. What was the,
what was the current events two years ago?
They were totally different
than they are now. Yeah. So,
so there's that.
So that's why little current events
thing as far as appealing to a larger
audience, that part of the question, well,
if my goal was to appeal to a large,
larger audience than I think I actually
would talk about the trending stories of
the day and put out little little
clips of soundbites of all this stuff.
And instead of,
instead of doing what I do now,
which is to read a hundred
year old out of print books,
like that's a great way
to build an audience,
or let's talk about the Rwandan genocide
or let's talk about the Holocaust,
or let's talk about the rape and Nan King,
or let's talk about the mee Lai massacre.
That ought to build a great audience.
So, so the idea that, oh, I'm trying to
build a larger audience. It's like, no,
actually people that want to
listen to this one to listen to it.
I'm not trying to, I'm not trying to
build an audience by manipulating what,
what I'm thinking about.
No, I'm actually, I'm,
I'm talking about and I'm diving into
what I find important and what I think I
can learn from and I get more out
of this podcast, isn't anybody,
I mean I know a lot of people say,
Oh, I've got a lot from your podcast.
I get more out of it than anybody cause
I get to dive deep into this stuff and
really look at it.
So no,
it's not the trying to appeal
to a larger audience. In fact,
if I wanted a larger yard,
large arts,
I'd do exactly what you're talking about
as far as the soldier's mentality of
not criticizing the commander in
chief over. I actually don't agree.
I don't agree that that's a soldier's
mentality and I don't believe that it
should be a soldier's mentality.
The soldier should question their
leadership and now should they do it
tactfully? Absolutely. Cause I don't
want to be surrounded by yes men. That's,
that's wrong. Also, if you at,
what am I trying to say? This is
just a general leadership principle.
What am I said a thousand
times on this podcast?
I'm trying to build a relationship
with a person above me in the chain of
command.
So when I was in the military,
if I wanted to have influence over
my boss, over my commander in chief,
what I outwardly criticize them
and make, make them think, oh,
this guy just doesn't like me.
I'm going to take my first chance to
get rid of them or not promote them. No,
I'm actually going to play the game and
I'm going to look and say, okay, boss,
Hey, I see what you're doing here.
I want to support what you're doing,
but does this make sense?
Can we do it a different way?
So I'm trying to build a relationship
with my boss up the chain of command.
I'm not trying to ostracize him by,
by making them look bad,
or by openly criticizing my boss
in, in, uh, in, Oh, in the open,
because what have I done? This is
my boss going to listen to me. No,
actually my boss isn't gonna
listen to me at all. So
yeah,
I don't want to be surrounded by yes men.
But at the same time,
if someone's making a bad decision,
if someone's doing something
that's a moral or legal,
I'll call him out on it all day long.
Now the other thing that happens here
is this is a new world and it's a bar,
and this is a binary world of sound bites.
That's what we've done.
We've created this binary,
binary world of sound bytes.
When most answers that you want to give
as a human being aren't one sentence or
two sentence on the far left or far right
or far light or far dark like there's
going to be,
you have to explain things a little bit
more and but when you take these binary
soundbites,
everyone's immediately thrown into an
extreme category on the far left or the
far right, and as soon, and here's the
bad part, here's the really bad part.
As soon as you get thrown
into one of those camps,
then have the other camp stops
listening to you completely. Yeah,
they stop listening to you.
Anything you say so you could,
you could make a great point,
but if you're on the other side,
doesn't matter.
No one's listening.
They don't want to hear it because you're
on the other side. You're the enemy.
It's a binary world.
You're either with me or against
me and there's no in between.
So that's kind of what we've created and
what I would rather do is have people
actually listen to what I say broadly
and make their own choices rather than me
trying to force an opinion down
their throat. This is the way it is.
This is the way it should be. And
by the way, just like leadership,
you can't force people. You can't
force an opinion down someone's throat.
If it doesn't work, you can't.
Sure it'll work for 30 seconds.
It'll work for five minutes and to work
for five days in a leadership position.
Yeah, you better do what I say
my way's right. Eventually you,
that kind of leadership does not work.
And it's the same thing with trying to
force an opinion down someone's throat,
throat.
If you listen to what I'm saying,
you can form your own opinion and I would
rather have you do that because that's
going to be stronger than some opinion
that I tried to force down your throat.
Yeah.
Which doesn't work by the way.
So I would rather people listen to me and
not just sound bikes and see where I'm
coming from holistically and see where
they can agree and disagree and see what
feedback they give me.
Because by the way,
I could be wrong about something
which I have no problem with.
But I would rather do that.
I would rather have that
approach then join the pack,
whichever pack that has joined the pack
on the street and bark loudly like the
rest of the dogs.
I have no interest in doing that.
So there you go.
Thank you.
And it's funny, man, you're,
you're like one of the few people
who don't even know, you know,
like that whole thing.
I mean to sum that up,
I mean I've heard that before where
someone would be like, Hey, I'm, you know,
I'm like this one. But it's so
it's so few people that actually
do that the way the way you do, even in
real life, like in real life, like he,
you don't,
even when political stuff will come up,
it's real obvious that you didn't
jump in to any specific group.
Yeah.
So this,
this really ties back to last week's
podcast of getting involved in things that
don't matter.
And there is,
there's just so much out
there that doesn't matter.
Now where you have to be careful is that
that there's so many things that don't
matter. But what I am not saying
that little things don't matter.
You see what I'm saying? There's a huge
disparity between those two things.
There's a lot of things that don't matter.
What I am not saying is that little things
don't matter because there are little
things that do matter and the classic
example that we brought up over and over
and over again on this podcast,
it's like, oh, the Russian soldiers,
not shaving and Chechnya and how
that led to there eventually. Okay,
not gonna Shave now.
We're not gonna clean our weapons now.
Now we're not gonna stay awake on a watch.
Now we're not going to execute.
The missions were being told to do.
Now we're getting beat.
There are little things that matter,
but if I'm barking day long
about things that don't matter,
then we have a problem. We have a
problem now I'll tell you something else.
There has been some issues
that have come up lately.
There was one issue that I was going
to address on the podcast, but,
and I still might address it because it's
a small problem that I see as being a
more significant problem and
if it continues down the road,
but luckily at this point there's,
there's a whole pack of dogs
barking about it. It wasn't like,
it wasn't like I noticed this problem.
No one else saw it. It was like,
I noticed this problem,
so did millions of other people and
they all those dogs start barking. Okay,
so now what am I going to do? Good
bargain with them. It's like, okay,
now if there comes a time where all of
a sudden I realized there's one of these
small things that matter or a big things
that matter that I don't see getting
the traction that it needs,
well then I will absolutely say,
Hey,
this is what I think about this situation.
Generally there's so many people barking
and they're barking about the same
thing. They're barking about a
lot of things that don't matter.
They're barking about some things that
matter and right now, unless, I mean,
what do I say all the time you,
the less, the less you speak,
the more people listen.
Yeah.
So if I want to give my my
opinion on the Daily News,
every hour on the hour, no one's
listened to anything I've got to say,
and then it's a waste.
It's a waste.
It's a waste of my time
because there's more important,
there are more important
things when we can,
when we can dive into human
nature through the lens of war,
through the lens of leadership,
through the war of a traffic.
If we can learn and teach people about
the past so that we can prevent it from
happening in the future.
That to me is infinitely more impactful
than barking about some current event
that's happening. That's going to be
gone in a week. It's amazing how far,
how fast stuff comes up on the radar.
It's all over the headlines and in a week
it's gone. In a week it's gone. Yeah.
So I just not going to play
that game. I have. I don't,
there's no point in doing it.
That's a really good way to put it.
It's like these current events,
most of the time seem to be shaped in
a way to just for dogs to bark about,
you know,
what it is like here and then,
then the bark and the next thing you
know. Yeah. Okay. Mark about this now the,
the sound bite thing is really interesting
too that everything is a sound bite
and it either puts you in one camp or
the other camp and the fact of the matter
is you can't put me in a camp.
You can't cause I got beliefs
that you don't understand.
On one side. On the other side.
Yeah. You know, and so what?
You can't talk to me about
that kind of thing. You can't,
not that you can't talk to me,
you can't put me in a camp,
but the instinct of the world right now
is take that person and put him in a
camp. I'm not going to the
camp. That's what's happening.
If you want to figure it out,
what I'm thinking. Listen,
what I'm saying about listen to what
I'm saying in hundreds and hundreds and
hundreds of hours where I talk
about human nature, right?
If you want to figure that out and then
you want to ask me a pointed question
about something cool. Ask. Bring it. If
it's something that's going to, if it's a,
if it's a bark,
if you want me to bark about something,
I'm probably not going to bark about it
for what? Throwing you in a camp. All
you'd have is a whole lot of unhappy
be campers. No, you throw me in a
camp. If you put me in one camp,
the other camp doesn't listen
to anymore. Yeah. And that,
and that means their minds are closed,
so they're not going to,
and is the fact of the matter is there's,
there's good people in
both camps know and,
and both people can be,
can be,
can change and come can accept
new ideas if their mind is open,
if their mind is open, they're
just staying there, camp
and everyone else. I mean,
when you watch the extremes of either
camp right now, it's, it's like,
it's like really, it's, it's bizarro
world. That's kind of odd. Yeah. So you,
you just sit there and say, okay,
what, why am I going to play that game?
Let's just become better people that
understand people better and will make
better, make the place,
make the world better.
Can't disagree. Okay. Yeah.
The whole unhappy campers though than me
more than making a joke. I dig it. Yeah.
No, it was a good attempt at humor. Well,
actually, no, it wasn't. It was a failure,
but that's cool. Oh, what was
the other point you made? Uh,
sometimes it's better to just, just try,
you know, and, oh, the whatever thing.
Yeah, yeah, yeah. No, I know. And then
now, you know, don't try that again.
No more jokes from Echo Charles.
Learn from my mistakes. Anyway.
Next question. What is the best way
to break through a plateau in Jujitsu?
I'm stuck doing the same moves against
the same training partners that have the
same moves done to me beating the same
guys and getting beat by the same guys.
What should I do?
Yeah,
what should he do? Well, I'll
tell you what I would do.
Go on a crazy training binge. Yeah, take,
take a week off from work
and train eight hours a day.
Just get crazy it.
Make sure you're healthy and then take
a week off and train eight hours a day.
Like nuts.
That's number one.
Number two, you could also opposite.
Take a short break, take a little time.
Don't take a long break. Take a little
step back. That's another option.
Another option is only start working on
certain moves. Like only utilize one,
like, okay, so every time
you get a arm lock from the
bottom of you, you got to be,
you're a guard player. Don't
play golf anymore. Yeah.
Don't click guardian more a start.
Just look,
I'm not going to play guard every time
I'm going to come up and I'm going to get
us, I'm going to go for a single
leg from the bottom like dean does.
I'm gonna do that every time
until I started making it work.
That's what I'm going to do.
And if I get choked a thousand times,
that's fine cause I'm going to
get better at it eventually.
And other thing is
trained, like, you know,
you get your little click of
training partners at your gym,
starched the training with some of the
other people that have different body
styles and big different body shapes.
So you get used to,
you have to bring out a new part of your
game. The first one that I talked about,
training binge eight hours a day.
I know it's hard for people to
actually make that happen. The w the,
The Times that I've done that,
the first time I did it,
I actually do is at the time
that I taught the, uh, the Jocko,
the Jujitsu for off fence,
the Jujitsu offense for combat
killing operations Jacko course.
And I trained these guys.
It was a small group,
it's like five of us and we trained all
day and one of the guys was equivalent
to me. Uh, Dan, he was like,
we were both like blue belts.
And so we normally,
we were teaching people,
but we were training long and like my
Jujitsu visibly got better in a five day
period because I trained super
hard for five straight days.
So that's a cool way. You could
probably do it for a weekend, you know,
probably just like a three, take a Friday
off trade Friday, Saturday, Sunday,
eight hours a day, work on some stuff.
Yeah, be careful, you know, because you,
you get your over use injuries and
or do you get, when you're tired,
you're more likely to get hurt. So you
got to use a little caution. But yeah,
those are some good ways to break your
plateaus in Jujitsu, which we all,
we all hit one way to know that
you're breaking your plateaus,
you're going to get worse first.
You're gonna get, you're gonna lose,
you're gonna lose to some of these
guys that you have been tapping because
you're trying something new. Yeah, yeah.
That is an indicator for sure. Yeah.
The,
I like the do certain moves or omit
certain loose cause like it's a natural
thing where like you, when you're,
you're, when you're ascending, right?
When you're getting,
when you're training,
you kind of settle into a certain type
of game, you know? So maybe, yeah.
You like to play guard a lot.
Maybe like to get the triangle from the
guard a lot. That's your kind of go to,
you know,
where it,
it becomes sort of this almost like a
muscle memory kind of thing where it's
like boom,
you'll pull guard your routine in a role
no matter who you're going against it.
It's real similar all the
time. Right. Um, so yeah,
if you start omitting that stuff
where it's like, okay, I'm not,
I won't go for that triangle anymore.
I'll play guard,
but it cannot do the triangle.
So it forces you to do other stuff.
And then sometimes depending on your
experience, you might have two, three,
four go tos, right? So you still,
you still kind of trapped in that same
plateau by if you just omit one move.
So in that case,
you think of a move that you might
notice other people getting a lot,
not necessarily on you, but you know,
just in general and be like, Hey, I'm,
that's all I'm going to do. I can't
get any other submission. I can't,
I can only do, I don't know the
Guillotine for example. Right.
Let's say you just don't do
guillotines that much or whatever.
I know you can't relate to
that, but you say, okay,
I'm only going for guilty if I'm like
in my guard. I can't really like,
I can't really get a guilty tunes from
the guard or whatever it put it this way.
If you're not good at Guillotines,
that'll force you to find ways to
get the guilty. It'll just force
you. And then if you do
that for one thing that we,
I would say maybe even like three months,
maybe in six months,
Brian Sergeant was like, Hey, yeah,
like I what I did I cause he liked,
he likes to play on top, smashed from the
top. He's like, I had it for six months.
I just didn't play on top. Well that
might've been you who said that? I Dunno.
One of you guys said that that
definitely happened with me. Yeah.
It definitely happened with me. I
didn't like being on the bottom. Yeah.
And then I just had to just like,
okay. Yeah. No sweeps allowed. Um, no,
like starting from the top. If you're, if
you're starting to pull guard, that's it.
Like, no, that's your rule. And
that's the thing. It's hard to like,
it's hard to come to training unless
you have this plan in your mindset.
It's hard to come to train and be like,
you know what?
I think I'm going to just only play
guard today if like you don't like garden
cause it's like I don't want to get
like tapped out everybody, you know,
especially when you just got your
purple belt or something like this.
It's hard to do that. But yeah,
if you just make up your mind,
kind of think of it long term,
like I'm playing the long game here and
just only go for that certain move that
you want to get good at it.
That's all you're doing. It'll,
that'll bus you plot pass
the plateau easy. It'll,
I don't know about easy way
to walk through your plateau,
but I think that's a very high probability
that you'll, you'll get past it.
And also, uh, just not easy cause you
just, it's more of your plastic plateau.
Easy. It's not easy. Yeah.
But it was actually hard.
Yeah. Yeah. Okay. And I did,
I just do, I just want to make sure
people aren't like, Oh, you know,
Echo said to just try one move and then
it's going to be easy to break them. No,
that's actually not true.
That's actually hard to, it's a,
it's hard to not just resort back
to what you're good at and B,
when you don't resort to what you're
good at and you get your ass kicked on a
regular basis,
which is not fun and easy,
and that easily could be the two main
challenges of going through Jujitsu
journeys. Those two things.
Yeah. Arguably, yes,
you are right. Correct.
That is absolutely correct.
If that's what you mean by easy,
what a kind of sorta meant was you'll
the probability of breaking pastors have
surf spot that I surf at.
Yes.
And one of the ways to get out of
the water is dangerous book fast.
The other way to get out
of the water is mellow,
but it's a longer walk and I was surfing
with my buddy stoner and he's like,
Hey, which way is it easier to
get out? And I said, well Bro,
it depends on which is why he's here.
Yes sir.
Because one of them's not more than
a few steps. Once you're good. Yeah,
we're getting good. Is getting to
that point is it is a challenge.
The other way is real easy,
but it's a long walk.
So it just depends what you mean
by easy. Yeah. So I mean to me,
probability wise,
let's say if you chose to break through
your plateau by going to another gym to
train with all different guys,
that will get you past your plateau.
But I think if you did this thing where
you omit a certain move or you just add
a move,
they not good.
And that's the only way if you did that
and really committed to it correctly,
which is hard by the way mentally. But
if you did that, I think, I think you,
the probability of you breaking pass
your plateau and ending up at a further
place in regards to progress is
much higher if you did that. Yeah,
that's what I think. And that's what I
meant by easy, which I guess, yeah, that,
Gosh, I'm gonna use the word easy.
Depends what you mean by using scratch.
Watch me also, uh, do tournament
plenty. If you do a lot of
tournaments, bro, you'll,
you'll bus bus pass the plateau. Yeah.
Weaknesses will be exposed. Yeah.
And it's like you'll, you're mine would
be way more at ease in training too.
It'll be like more open. It's weird for
sure. I think so. Anyway. Next question.
How do you apply the principle of building
a relationship with your boss when
your boss doesn't value relationships,
for example,
he consistently avoids interactions that
don't lead directly to a deliverable on
a current objective.
He avoids all other interactions such
as those that are for the purpose of
building relationships and
chemistry within the team. Okay.
What would I do in that situation?
While the Nica obviously what I would
do is I would build a relationship based
on deliverable current objectives,
right? If that's what he's into,
I'm going to make that happen.
Like I'm going to be the guy that he
thinks can get this to happen and that's
what our relationship is going to
be based on and I'm fine with that.
When he wants to talk about work, I will
talk about work. I had bosses like that.
I had plenty of bosses like that and
what do you do when you have bosses like
that and play the game like, okay, we're
going to, let's just make this happen.
Let's do this
now let me say this beat beat
because he isn't personable.
This means that you have
to be more personable,
not so much with him but with the rest
of the team because there is a lacking
element within the team that you as a
good team player and team member and
leader, whether you're in a positional
leadership or just a human leader,
you can improve the team by building
some of that human connection that bonds
the team more so.
Even though my boss is in personable
and is just about the business and just
about the current objective,
that's fine with me.
I'm going to do my best to support him
and make him realize that I'm going to
got the guy that's going to make those
objectives work and I'm going to build
the human connection with the rest of the
team which will make our team stronger.
Now I am not going to offend my boss by
being the guy that is more popular than
him.
Some people have some,
some people that have the attitude
that this individual's talking about,
what would you call this person? Um,
just just a hundred percent work focused.
So if I've got a guy
that's 100% work focused,
sometimes that kind of boss finds
the person that wants to chat.
Annoying. Right? Unknowing
which is possible. So you don't
want wanna you don't want to be,
you don't want to annoy the
boss and he thinks all this,
all this guy joggle he just wants to
build friends. He's not here to work. No,
you gotta be careful about that. And,
and, and the weird thing is, honestly,
I'm very work focused.
Okay.
I'm very work focused and I have to like,
I don't really have to do anymore,
but I used to like, I'd have to
consciously think about, okay, on top of,
actually I still do have to do it.
Sometimes you don't like,
I have to consciously think about like,
okay,
I also need to like be nice and build
relationship with the person that I don't
normally interact with. Right?
So you, you do have to do that.
So form the relationship with the rest
of the team, the good relationship,
and then form the best relationship that
you can with the boss and that is going
to help the whole team. That's
it. It's as simple as that.
And I'll say one more thing about this.
Yeah.
You don't get to pick your
leader generally. You don't
get to pick your leader,
but you can pick the relationship
that you have with your leader. Yeah.
So what your leaders into, let's get in
the game. Let's build a good relationship.
Uh, once again, if someone's
out there thinking, oh,
so you just want me to kiss ass.
What I'm saying is not that I
want you to kiss ass, I'm singing.
I want you to win.
That's what I'm saying.
Because the better relationship
you build with your boss,
the more influence you have over them,
the better chance you
have of getting promoted,
the better chance you have
of of accomplishing the
mission and taking care of
your team. That's,
that's the way it works.
Why don't want to get promoted so I
can get more money for myself. No,
I want to get promoted so I can do the
mission so I can take care of my team.
That's why I want to get promoted.
If it was just about like taking care of
myself, I wouldn't go work for this guy.
I'd go find another job
and pick a different boss.
Cause you do get to pick your boss, you
can quit your job, quit your day job.
So that's what you do.
You build that relationship
hard as it is gets up. Yeah.
That's a good point.
With the d with the kind of the details
of it where you can't just start trying
to chat the guy up. He doesn't like
that. Yeah. No one does actually. Yeah.
Even if you're a social person,
but you're for,
let's say you're just focused
on something, you know
and I dunno, you focusing on in your
friend calls you and you're like,
oh well they called me. It
might be important. Yeah, yeah.
And they're telling you about, you know,
the episode of whatever last night.
And he was like, Bruh, I'm working right
now, but I don't watch TV. Call me again.
Oh yeah, now you're going to step
step further than I had in mind.
But I'm just saying that that's
annoying no matter who you are.
So if you're thinking, you
know, this boss is like, he,
he doesn't like to quote unquote build,
build relationships and like all this
stuff, he's only then you're going to,
you written, you run that risk of
annoying them. Yes. You've got to be a,
make a big step back,
dichotomy,
dichotomy, dichotomy. But there's little
end. Usually it has to do with time too,
you know?
So if you go in and you just go,
just little digs of like relationship
building stuff but not, don't take,
don't go in there and be like,
hey did you catch the game last night?
Didn't do that. Like I don't care.
I can stop. But you know, I dunno.
Nice tie, boom out, you know,
kind of thing. I Dunno. Don't
say nice to, I don't know.
Next question.
The guy that's high level worker does not
want to hear about his tie is not care
about his time. Yeah. But it actually
is noise. A lot of people. But yeah.
And I don't know how to get it in the
corporate scenario. I think my whole life.
But yes.
So I don't know,
that just seemed like something on the
movies and long finger about your shirt.
No, it wasn't corporate though. The night
club leadership. Yeah, same for sure.
And the point is,
there's things you can say that don't
take up his time and necessarily his full
attention to annoy him that you can
say or do. That's what I'm saying.
I don't know what that is cause I don't,
I don't know. I don't work with you guys.
Check. Next question. Hey Jocko,
my boss is trying to implement.
I say postulates highlighted my boss.
I don't know why it's,
it's highlighting all my bosses
works man. Somebody was talking about
on social media how you said, ps,
you're like, I went to the grocery
store, I got some peas, you know
it's a variable. Then
nonetheless, escalation.
Sure my boss is trying to implement a
process that I see the end result not
being what is needed and I have proposed
an alternative that is proven and will
add value to the company.
Do I give up trying to position to get
the outcome we need or do I commit to
help implement his process and wait
for the outcome then try it again.
It is a relatively small failure in the
big picture outcome but would like some
input on how to get the
results we need longterm.
Very cool question and
so yeah, you've got a scenario where
your boss wants to do something,
you know you got a better idea that
will work better. What do you do? Well,
first of all, any way that I
can make my idea and his idea,
that's what I'm gonna try and do. So
you have to be careful, and again,
I don't know what your boss
might be an open minded person.
If you've got a good leader, you
go in there and say, hey boss,
this is what you're trying to make happen.
I think this will work better.
And your boss May, Oh wow, that's a
great, that's a great idea. You know what?
Let's go with that. There's, there's
leaders out there that make it happen.
You're probably not asking this question.
If you have that kind of boss,
you're probably talking about someone
that has a little bit more ego,
thinks they thinks they know a little bit
more and not really open minded to new
ideas.
And that's why making your idea into
his idea is going to be a better option.
Don't try and force your idea.
And one thing you do is you could,
you could ask questions and
I've talked about this before,
but like you say something
like, you know, hey, hey boss,
I want to make sure that I'm supporting
this and the best way possible.
So I really want to understand this fully.
So can you explain this here to me
and why we're doing it like that.
And then you know, you have a conversation
with your boss and then you go, oh,
and maybe your boss has some good
points that you didn't understand.
Or maybe that opens the door
for you to say, Hey boss,
the way that this other group
is doing it is like this.
Do you think we could try that?
Or you say,
if you want to eagle him up a little bit,
it's like, hey boss, you know, I don't,
I don't fully understand this.
You know, as well as you do.
Could you just help me understand
why we're doing it this way?
And then once again, what you're doing
is you're starting a conversation.
If you can't get the message
across in that indirect manner,
you can be a little bit more direct,
but be careful when you're direct
with people. They dig in, man,
they dig in, especially with anyone.
If any kind of Edo Eagle, they dig in,
you tell them your idea and they just,
all of a sudden they,
they come up with reasons not to
do it and you have to be careful.
That's why you have to use
caution when you reveal your plan.
It's better to not even
review it as a year plan.
It's better to reveal it as like an
idea and then let it become their plan.
Don't reveal your emotions.
Okay?
Now if all that fails and this guy
is just dead set in, hey, we're no,
we're doing it my way. Shut
up. Echo. We're not. We're
not listening to your plan.
We're doing it my way. Then what
you do. Yeah, you go all in.
You support it the best of your ability.
You, you try and learn what they want.
You try and execute what they want.
You try and understand what they want
better than anyone else, including him.
So that way you go out, you execute,
you know where all the weaknesses are.
Now you learn and now you can come back
with a better argument or a better seed
to plant in their head. Hey boss, I
know your plan. It's working really,
really well. And one thing that we could
do to make it even better, I think,
what do you think of this? If we
did x, Y, z instead of x, Y, B,
I think it might work a little bit better.
What do you think? And then you, again,
you, you plant this, you plant
the team, and maybe, I mean,
you plant the seed and maybe
you can incorporate, you know,
there's times where there's
times where I did this, oh,
that's what you want to do,
boss. Cool. Got It. Yep.
That's when we do go and do something.
Same result, get the same result,
would do it a different way.
You know?
It's the ask for better to ask
for forgiveness than permission.
Yeah. Then then parish. So sometimes
it's like, it's like they began,
we're going back to the idea
of things that don't matter.
If my boss wants me to do it one way and
I can do it just a little bit different
and no one's gonna know and it's gonna
be all good and our results going to be
the better or the same. I'm probably
just can be like, hey boss, I got it.
And then hey bossy on the fly. We made
a little call here, we went with a y,
B or you know, Z da. Is that as
EDB? I hope it's not, you know,
bad.
But here's the results by the way.
We did an even shorter time than
a boss goes, oh yeah, that's cool.
It's no big deal.
Cause he sees the results and he wants
to take us a little bit credit forums.
So again,
what's this about?
This is about building the relationship.
So let me ask you this. This is,
this is an important for good
question to ask yourself.
Will,
what will help the team more?
What will help the team more?
Will it help the team or to disrupt the
relationship and undermine the boss?
Will that, will that help the
team? No. Will it help the team?
If you create an antagonistic
relationship with your boss,
know that won't help your team.
Will it help your team?
If you build a relationship with
your boss, if you unify the team,
if you strengthen the team and
you bring everyone together,
will that help the team?
Yes. It'll help the team.
Will that build the relationship
with your boss? Yes.
It will build a
relationship with your boss.
If you have a better
relationship with your boss,
is your boss more likely to accept the
influence that you're throwing at them?
Yes,
absolutely.
So I think that's something you can ask
yourself a lot is what I am trying to
do,
going to help the team or hurt the team.
And you actually have to look at those
two in the long term, in the search term.
Cause sometimes you do something that
hurts the team right now and it'll help
the team later. Like for instance,
Hey, we're going to fire a guy.
Everyone loves him, but, and
it's going to disrupt the team,
but longterm we'll be better
off sometimes that works.
Sometimes it's like we're
going to fire this guy.
Everyone loves him and it's
going to be a longterm down.
It's going to be a long term
detriment that you made this call,
so you have to check yourself and check
what's going to help. The longterm,
short term of the team is
going to make it better.
It's gonna make it worse in this case,
trying to make your plan your boss's plan.
If you can't,
then support,
build relationships and
influence over the longterm,
especially cause this guy very smart to
mention that this is a relatively small
failure, like this isn't a huge risk.
It doesn't he, you can. Hey boss,
you know what? We got it done.
Didn't quite go come the same way.
Here's where we're going.
So very good question
and a question. Similar question. Yeah.
This is why group this one together too.
We had a couple of groups questions.
This is one of them.
Jocko.
I was wondering what your advice is for
disagreeing up the chain of command.
Obviously this needs to be done
with some tact I eat in private,
not in front of others,
but in those private conversations,
how should one respectfully disagree?
Again, again, similar question.
A better technique than
disagreeing is just to ask
questions. You know, boss, Hey,
I want to make sure I get this right.
Can you explain it to me again? Can you,
can you watch me do it right? So your boss
actually sees what the problem is. Uh,
that way you're, you're not
being offensive. Hey boss,
can you explain why you chose this course
of action? I really want to learn from,
from what you do, what
you, the way you do it.
I again, does that sound like a kiss
ass? Yes. Cause I'm exaggerating.
You know what I mean? Hey boss,
you're so incredibly smart. No,
I'm not talking about that because
bosses don't like kit. Ask us if she's,
or at least good,
good bosses don't
actually even good bosses.
They might keep their kiss asses around,
but they don't respect him.
So you don't gain influence by being
a kiss ass. It's not a good situation.
So I'm not talking about kissing
ass, but you know, hey boss,
I'm really want to understand this and
make sure I understand it. Can you,
can you explain to me why this
is the best way to make this,
to do this versus the other way?
You know that's the kind of question
that's not kissing ass. That's actually,
you know what is actually
legitimately wanting to know.
Well like I legitimately want
to know maybe what if we,
instead of assuming that we
know better than our boss,
what if we assume that my
boss knows better than me?
Let's make that assumption.
And if you communicate with that
assumption then you're probably going to
communicate in a much better way then
communicating with the assumption that my
boss is an idiot and I
know better than him. Yeah.
Which is not a good way to communicate.
Yeah.
Funny when you eat, now that you kind
of said that about the kiss ass guy,
cause that comes up a lot cause I don't
want to be kissed ass and yeah you don't,
the kiss ass guy is the same
thing as being friend zoned.
You know what friends owned
mean? I do. It's the same
thing. Yeah. So like the girl,
right? Typically it's the guy
who gets friend zoned. Right.
Cause he's like two nights. He's too nice.
He's too whatever. He'll, it's, he's a,
he's essentially a, you're like a
brother to me. To me. Yes ma'am.
That's what he is.
So of course the girls going to keep them
around for all this like good feeling
superficially by the way mentioned launch,
all that stuff,
all the superficial stuff.
He's not going to get anywhere
of legitimacy with her
actual decision makings if
you translate that into the, you
know, working environment or whatever.
Well yeah the boss,
I mean a certain kind of boss just like
a certain girl is going to keep a guy
around for that reason.
Certain boss is going to be like,
yeah I'll keep him around.
I feel a little bit bad even firing the
guy like that a little bit cause he's
just so nice to me and gives me
all these compliments and even in,
in a weird way I think the kiss ass
guy kind of knows that too. You know,
like how,
why would he ever fire me even though
it's not negative your job or whatever.
Right. Um, because you know, he can't fire
me. I'm just too nice to him. You know,
there's that feeling is floating
around is what I'm saying.
But it's the same deal, right?
Like it's too many compliments.
You're too much of a yes man.
I'll keep you around for very superficial
reasons, but that's it brother.
You don't get past.
Yeah, that's, and that's not a good
place to be it. No, it's not sir.
That's why I'm not saying kiss ass.
And the way I just explained that of,
of actually assuming that
your boss knows more than you,
isn't is a good way to approach the
situation as opposed to approaching the
situation. Like you know more than
your boss. Why act like that dude,
the outcome isn't going to be inferior.
The outcome is inferior.
The outcome of,
of acting like your boss or assuming that
your boss knows more than you know the
outcome is you treat them with respect.
Because the other way you could try
and treat them with expects a respect,
but inadvertently you sound
like, you know, some people
we talk about normal face,
right? Some people they
cannot even ask a question
in an in a respectful way, right? They
can't even, what was I saying over here?
They can't even say, you know, hey boss,
can you explain this to me
cause I really want to honor,
they can't even say
that. You know, hey boss,
can you explain this to me because
this doesn't make any sense.
You know what I mean?
Like they can't even,
they can't even ask a question
in a respectful way. Yeah.
That's a skill you should master
as a leader and as a follower,
as a leader and as a follower.
How to ask questions and respectful way.
Lafe pointed this out. Lafe pointed
out, we were talking about the fact of,
of, I would say it's a story he's told a
bunch of times of going through the kill
house and he's in the back of the train
and you shouldn't be in the back of the
train. You should be somewhere
where you can lead everyone.
Cause when you in the back of the train,
you don't know what's happening in
the front of the train of assaulters.
A big group of people moving through
gills and I didn't and he goes, you know,
Jocko didn't say, Hey, stop doing
that and do it this other way is that.
He asked me questions and he's like,
they were real questions. I wasn't like,
Hey leaf, why the hell are
you in the back of the train?
Is that a respectful question? No, it's
not a respectful question, but it's like,
hey leaf w what are you doing
in the back of the train?
This is a respectful question.
I,
I'm actually assuming that maybe life
who doesn't have the experience that I
have, who's my subordinate as
a platoon commander. To me,
the big task unit commander, my assumption
is not that I know more than him.
My assumption is that he's
got a reason for that.
My assumption is that he knows more than
me. Yeah. Which, well, this is one of the,
one of Jordan Peterson's 12
rules for life. It's like a,
I think it's assumed the person that
you're talking to knows more than you.
What I'm saying is the same thing
up and down the chain of command.
You assume that your
boss or your subordinate,
no something that you
don't know and if you can,
if you can ask questions in that way,
instead of asking questions, boss,
what do we do in this for or life?
Why are you doing that?
Like why are you in the back of the train?
That's stupid. No, it's like, Hey, wait,
why are you in the back of the
train? What do you, what does it,
what is your purpose of being back there?
I genuinely, genuinely want to know,
and this isn't like, I'm not even
saying I'm acting like that. I truly,
genuinely want to know what the deal is.
So make the assumption up and down
the chain of command that your boss,
your subordinate,
knows more than you and then
ask good questions with true,
genuine curiosity that you
want to know the answers to.
It's a good way to go about it.
Next question.
I'm a young warehouse manager.
That takes ownership for anything
and everything that goes wrong.
This seems to offend like coworkers.
How can I fix it?
Um, okay. Classic Dichotomy.
Leadership quest shred there.
You've gone too far. That's what's
happened. You've gone too far.
So what you have to be do,
what you have to do is don't be offensive.
When you take ownership,
when you take ownership,
you can't be offensive.
When you take ownership.
Some people get offended by that. So when
you say, Hey, you know what? This is mine,
I got this. That bothers
some people when you say,
you know what,
this is my fault and I'm going to fix it.
That even that offend some people.
What the tone? Just the tone of like,
no, this is my fault. I got this. And
you do that three days, three times,
four times, five times and
all of sudden cause oh what?
Everything's his fault and as
he's got to fix everything they,
he doesn't think I can fix it.
Right.
You can offend people
with all kinds of stuff.
You don't have to work
very hard to offend people.
I mean there's people get offended
when you say something nice to him,
you know what I mean? You know
what I mean? I was watching, uh,
I met,
I met the ever seen the yoga dude that
does like yoga videos. He's got red hair.
His name was spears.
I met him just randomly getting
off a plane, but he's, he what?
I spears or Sears? Sears. I think it's
serious. Maybe speak, what'd I say?
Spears. I don't know because I
know the guy though. Yeah, he's
very funny guy. Very cool guy. And I
was, once I met him, I was laughing.
I was checking out a couple of videos,
but one of them was,
you know how to be offended
at all things. And it's, it's,
it's hilarious because that's
exactly what people do.
People,
some people can get offended by anything.
So that's what you got to watch out for.
Even when you're taking ownership,
people can actually be offended
by that if you go too far.
So instead of overtly stepping up and
taking ownership in this particular case,
then you can tell what's going on here.
My brother here, young warehouse manager,
he's fired up. He wants to make things
happen. He wants to get after it,
and so what does he do? He's like,
Oh, I read extreme ownership.
I'm going to take ownership of everything,
and that's a great attitude to have except
for you can offend people when you go
too far because you got to read the
second book that I got into leadership so
that you can, you can balance that out
a little bit. So instead of saying like,
Hey, this is mine, I'm going to take
ownership of this and make it happen.
Instead you look and you
say, Hey, you know what?
Do you want me to take care of
this? Oh, hey, you know what?
That's probably in my department.
You want me to take care of that?
So that way or like,
hey,
it seems like this should be
something I should take care of.
You want me to handle that
instead of me, me, me, me.
I got to ask the question the
other day at a Q and a in the core,
the question started off with the
person started the question with,
I've got the mode, I've got the question
that everyone in here needs answered.
So, so, so out of the gate I was like,
okay, so we have a situation here, right?
Because that immediately tells you
that in that person's head they've got,
they've got the question
that needs answered.
So there's already an ego scenario
happening like out of the gate.
So same thing here. You
don't know if you're going to
touch someone's Egos, right?
So when you say, look, this is
my deal and I'm going to fix it.
Like some people will take
offense to that. So again,
you soften those a little bit. Try and
give credit up the chain of command,
right?
Try and give it credit down the chain of
command instead of all take ownership.
It's like, hey, we got w, what did you
say? We when, when credit gets doled out,
get past that credit on, pass it to
your peers passage, your subordinates,
pass it to your boss.
So that's it.
Take ownership. What you need
to do at this point, young man,
is take ownership of being offensive.
And when you do that,
you're going to be less offensive.
You're going to be more covert. A guests,
remember I said earlier, like you
don't get to pick the boss. You,
you don't get to pick your boss,
you,
but you get to pick the
relationship you have with it.
You don't get to pick your, your peers.
You don't get to pick your subordinates.
You get your team, okay.
Hey, can you pick them? Yes,
you can quit your job. Can you
hire the right people? Yes you can,
but look what you got is what you've got.
You've got to work with them.
You don't everyone up, man.
I wish everyone was more
fired up like I am. Like,
that's not going to go well.
You know,
it's great that you wish that
that's not going to go well.
What you have to do is you
gotta you gotta, you gotta.
Here's another one. This is
similar, right? Millennials.
Well, Hey, one of the things that, what
are the things, this is a very simple,
I've done, I've done the millennium
questions a thousand times and you know,
the Vietnam veterans, the Vietnam
draft, these compared to them like, hey,
we can talk about that again. We
don't need to. But if you've got a,
if you're in charge of millennials
and you think to yourself,
millennials thinks everything's,
they think everything
centers around them. What,
what do you do as a leader?
You know what I do as a leader?
I make everything centered around them
and then they perform and then they get
after it.
And as they grow up,
they learned that everything doesn't
send around them. But I bring them there.
But why? Because I formed a relationship.
Why? Because I listened to him. Why?
Because I understand them.
Hmm.
So you don't get the team that you want.
You don't get the boss that you want.
What you do is you play the game up
and down the chain of command and form
relationships up and down the
chain of command that you want.
What relationships do you want
from up the chain of command?
You want them to listen to you.
You want them to give you what you need.
Do you want them to get out of your
way and let you do the mission?
What about down the chain of command?
You want them to support what's happening.
You want them to get after their job.
You want them to step up and lead.
That's what you want.
If you have an antagonistic relationship
because your millennials think
everything's about them,
well then guess what?
You're not going to be able to have any
influence on them. Any real influence.
You can have the imposed will on them
[inaudible]
but the imposed will is a
is a paper tiger, right?
It's not real. It only lasts when you're
there and guess what they're doing.
They're looking for another job.
So take ownership of being offensive
and be less offensive and more covert.
And you know what bro?
Young warehouse manager keep getting
after it and it will pay off.
And the fact that you're fired
up and you're crushing it,
crush it with a little bit more tact and
you're going to one day you're going to
be making it happen.
Yeah.
We got time for one more question.
To add though, a little tip, I think that,
I think you taught this too actually.
I realized this one I embraced
extreme ownership. You can't say, Hey,
I'm going to take extreme ownership of
this. Like it's, it's one of those things,
it's like just like taking
the high ground, right?
You get in like a thing with somebody,
you can't say I'm going to do it,
take the high ground and then
it doesn't work like that.
Like it just gave them the high ground.
When you announced that you
were taking the high ground,
gave it up exactly the right.
Same thing.
We've picked stream partnership in the
situation, so if you're a very good point,
I get it man, when you're
like, you know I'm taking,
and he even said I take ownership of
anything and everything that goes wrong.
Anything like straight up, he's your
guy. Right? Solely, it might indicate,
I'm not saying he's doing this, but he
could be going, hey guys, no worries.
I'm taking extreme ownership
of this situation. You know,
like if you say that kind of stuff.
Yeah, I could see that would,
but what's odd, and this is a very good
thing to understand about human nature,
everyone's jealous of you.
Everyone's jealous of each other.
Everyone's jealous of everyone else.
No one wants you to win. Right.
It's just like,
so when this guy is stepping up and
the crowd starts to pick at them,
they start to pick at them
and didn't want to pick them.
They want to pull them apart.
That's generally what the
crowd wants to do to you.
When you step up,
when you elevate yourself,
generally crowd wants to pick it you or
pull you back down. Does he think he is?
Yeah, exactly. Exactly. So
if you were aware of that,
then you can combat it by when instead
of elevating yourself in an overt manner
where everyone can see you saying,
I'm going to take ownership this
right now and get it solved. No use.
If I can say, hey, you know what?
This is probably my fault. Do you?
Do you want me to? I've let me. Let me
try and take some time and get it fixed.
Everyone goes there actually
kind of happy. They're like,
yeah, it was your fault.
They kind of, they're kind
of like, it's okay with them,
whereas opposed to I'm going to take
ownership and there's this dichotomy of
leadership. You're read extreme ownership.
Awesome. You got to read dichotomy to
push.
When something goes wrong, I freeze up
opposite of the know, like I freeze up,
I get stagnant. I don't want to
move. I just asked myself, why me?
I've tried saying good,
but it's not getting me moving forward.
Any advice
you ask yourself?
Why me?
So
saying good.
That should fix your attitude,
but that alone,
that alone will not fix your problems.
If you're having problems. Sure. Say Good,
that's perfect,
but then don't ask yourself,
why me?
Instead ask yourself,
now what am I going to do about it?
What are you going to do about?
Ask yourself that question
and then figure it out.
Figure out what you're going to do.
Say to yourself, I am going to detach.
I am going to assess the situation.
I am going to come up with a
plan and I am going to execute
and then start moving. It's,
it's not going to be a perfect plan,
but take action action that moved
you in a positive direction.
And if it ends up being the
wrong direction, that's fine.
At least you've learned where not to go.
Now,
where this gets tough is if
it is something that seems
like it's completely out
of your control and you know what?
Some things are completely out
of your control and that's fine.
And when that happens, you ask
yourself, what can I control?
What can I control that will make
this situation a little bit better?
And then you go,
don't get crushed by things going wrong.
Ask Yourself,
what am I going to do?
And then go do it.
And I think that's all
I've got for tonight.
So Echo Charles, speaking of, uh,
moving in the right direction,
I know you've got some things that can
help us move in the right direction.
What do you got for us? Yeah. Okay,
so dude, you did too. That's it.
That's a good one.
So still the path has
what Ma many directions,
but it's all in the same general
direction. It's the improvement.
It's improvement. There's different
roads on the path. Yes. Which is a really
weird thing to say. Yeah. It's
more of a general thing anyway,
but do you just do the universal,
in my opinion,
I am assuming in your opinion to where
if you're not doing Jujitsu more so than
I would say like that's terrible.
I'm not going to say that,
but I'm saying if you go through life and
not do Jujitsu and you're on the path,
you might be left maybe missing out.
You know what's really cool
about this podcast? Yes.
And about people listening this podcast
and about people starting Jujitsu,
this is the coolest thing. Two years
ago I would've been like, hey, you know,
you should try Jujitsu.
It's really good.
But I couldn't like confirm
how universal so many people,
I just,
so many people after they take their
first class or the first nine classes or
first three classes, they were like,
I'm addicted. Yeah. Why is that?
Because there's something special about
Jujitsu, so you should train it. Yeah,
that's it. Yeah. When you can
draw them. The parallel of Meta,
it's the metaphor for life. [inaudible]
told me that early on actually,
you know we're interested with
David Maister philosopher.
They didn't have to take philosopher and
undergo val illustrated some points in
a big one that undergo val
said that I will never forget.
It's like you through his, like
his life, so considered Jujitsu.
Like if you turn your back
on your problems in Jujitsu,
they're going to get worse and let's
face it. That's in especially early on.
That's how you get a guy to turn.
That's how you get a choke,
right when you're mounted on somebody,
he slapped him in the face. What and why?
If you get slapped in the face of what
do you want to do, turn your back, right?
Like, Oh, don't stop my face.
That's how you get the choke.
So under law says and Juditha you turn
your back and you give your back to your
opponent. That's the worst thing you
can do. But it's hard to face some.
Usually you got to work, you
know, same thing in life.
Men turn your back on your problems,
those problems and to get you,
and you've heard me say
that at the monster. Yes.
You turn your back on your problems, they
don't go away, they actually get worse.
And it's the same exact thing
in Jujitsu. Joke you. Yes.
Getting per Jagers behind your back.
So it's cool now to get feedback from
thousands of people that have now gotten
into Jujitsu game.
And the feedback I've got probably
I think three people out of many,
many.
And this isn't one of yours where you
say like a lot of people and it's like
four.
I'm talking to thousands of people.
I've gotten three that don't like Jujitsu.
Hmm. That does. They just don't like it.
And that's why I came up with a rule.
Okay. If you don't like it, that's fine.
Train at least until you've submitted
someone that's kind of equivalent and then
you can stop. And the reason I think, I
think that's actually, once you do that,
you'll,
you'll understand you too.
Cause sometimes you just
don't even understand it.
Sometimes people just can't comprehend it.
They count cock can't comprehend what's
happening and it's just too much. Yeah,
it's too much. Yeah. And so
they don't want to do it. Yeah.
But if you do it long enough
that you submit someone,
then you get that little like wow.
It's incredible.
Like at the muster when you,
when you show the connection of
two moves, yeah, this I could go,
it's like amazing.
Oh yeah.
And then when you try to explain that
every move is connected that way because
that's a biggie network. But,
but people don't understand
that Jujitsu is not just moves,
that it's all this group thing together.
This symphony of movement language.
That was good.
Anyway.
When you do it,
you're going to need a g cause you're
going to do [inaudible] and no Gaeton Suki
and rash card. That's the uniform.
We'll call it a uniform. Sure.
So you got to origin cause you're going
to get an origin g it's the best one.
Origin, main.com or just sometimes we
forget to say that, which is not good.
I feel like, I forget to say that the
name is origin. We, I say origin Maine.
Oh, okay, cool. But you'll, yeah, you'll,
you'll come to realize that it's very
obvious that origin is the only kind of
gate that you'll want slash need
all made in America by the way.
The threads are me. Throw that out
there and just like, oh by the way,
like it's made America, no, it's not
just something you throw out there.
It's a big deal. We're
talking about Allume multiple.
I actually, I actually had this, uh,
so I was talking to is
actually my literary agent and
I was like, well, you know,
like I said, it turns out, um,
you know, they're not going,
they can't put out Mike in the dragons
before November. So I'm just going to,
you know, Miss, make this book myself,
I'm starting a publishing company. Yeah.
And she's like, well, you know, a lot
of people try that. But you know it's,
there's a lot more to it, you know,
it's really hard. Yeah. And I was like,
okay, cool. Do you know
what a Loomis I go,
my friends up in Maine brought a loom
back from the grave and weave material
from cotton and nylon does so together.
The loom 9,000 [inaudible]
is 9,000 pounds. Their,
it has 5 million threads in going into it.
It's got,
it's got millions of parts inside of it.
It was rusted.
You're gonna tell me we can't get
photocopy some stuff and put it out in the
book. I got this, I
got this. Don't, don't.
And it's funny cause I told
that to Brian and Pete. I was,
I was laughing so hard because,
because really what's, what,
I don't even know if I could think
of something harder than saying, oh,
we're going to drag a loom out of a
dam abandoned factory in Lewiston,
Maine,
one loom left.
The rest of them have been sent overseas
during the economic downturn. Oh,
we'll just, we'll just
outsource, nevermind. Outsource.
We're just going to send our bread and
butter our American hardware overseas and
let someone else make it. There
was one loom left. And guess what?
We got it origin.
But yeah.
So you're telling me that we can take
this old loom that's 30 years old that
hasn't been run,
that's rusted and dirty and abandoned
and bring that thing back to life.
You're telling me we can't print some
books and get 'em out to my people.
You're wrong. Watch me straight up
wrong. Get some Jocko publishing.
Yup.
And that loom does not only make Giza and
rash guards, by the way, multiple looms.
By the way. It wasn't just that they
know it was one lumen forsee in with yes.
And now there's three looms. Rocking
and rolling. Yeah. Yeah. So yeah,
you can get shirts and joggers
and sweats, sweats, uh,
named
named,
I dunno, but named, we'll say
named the most comfortable sweats,
sweats in the world. Straight up the
joggers. I proclaimed straight up mill,
most comfortable pencil world. None
the less. Find out for yourself anyway.
Or did you mean.com to make a lot of
cool, good stuff. All made in America,
by the way.
Yeah. And that includes in
America supplements, Jocko,
Jocko supplements.
You know the Jocko thing is just
to complete a lack of originality.
That's what it is. Because when you think
about it from a broader perspective,
and you know me well enough to be like,
the last thing I would do is like, oh,
I'm just going to call everything Jocko.
It's like bizarro though.
When you started with the podcast,
it started with Jocko podcast and that,
I've said this before,
but I was on Tim Ferriss's
podcast and he was, he said like,
are you hungry? And I was
like, Jocko hungry. Yeah.
And for some reason that
just made me chuckle.
And then when we were naming this
podcast, I was like, well, you're like,
what are you gonna call him?
Like Jocko podcasts as if it's the same
knee Andra fall things. And so then,
then it was like, okay, we're
going to make tea. Well,
what do you call pomegranate white tea?
What are we going to call it?
Like the vedic solution. I mean, we
didn't get to call it. It's like, okay,
well this,
it's going to be the tea that I drink,
so we'll just called Jocko
white tea. Okay, cool. Well
then, hey, when I, when I,
when I started saying, you know what,
I need to make some good supplements,
Pete and Brian in the game, like
I'm like, Hey, can you make this?
And they're like, yeah. And I said, okay,
well then what are we going to call it?
We'll just call it, you know, so I'll
go Jocko. Supercross and there you go.
So that's how we ended up with the least
creative name of any products that have
existed.
I apologize to everyone
actually. It seemed like,
well, early on anyway,
it seemed like it wasn't creative
because you're like, hey, this create,
like if I create this super creative name,
like is that important?
Really great now.
No,
I'm too busy making it good.
Cool.
We talked about in the last podcast that
sometimes I'm so into functionality,
yeah. That I don't need, that I'm not in,
in synchronicity with the rest of
the world. Sometimes. For instance,
if you allowed me to design a house,
no human being would live in the house
except for me and like three other seals
that I know that'd be like, Oh
yeah, this house is perfect. Right?
Everyone else to be like, Bro,
what is wrong with you? He said,
you know you have keep
that same with vehicles.
Like if I could design my own vehicle,
no one would want to drive. It bumped me.
Maybe that's,
that one may be a little bit broader
because you get people that'd be like year
or so.
I have to be careful because sometimes
I'm just so into function that it just
doesn't make sense to anyone else but me.
Yeah,
but it does have its value big time when
it comes to these supplements because
what joint warfare function,
try lose function and your joint and see
what happens. Same thing with Krill oil.
Same thing with discipline, brain
function, and then of course milk.
That's muscle function and muscle
building function recovery,
if you will still look all of them
together, brain function, joint function,
muscle function,
boom. You're good to go. Yeah.
Yeah. And speaking of functionality,
and this is one of the things
where you kind of attacked me, sir,
you attacked me because for you,
you see this is,
this is a perfect example in your
mind. I'm all about function. Right.
Then when I started making supplements,
I wanted them to taste
good and that was actually,
it was actually side by side with
functionality is taste. Why is that?
Because if you don't,
if it doesn't taste good,
then it's not gonna function cause
you're not going to use it. Yeah.
So these tastes delish yeah,
especially mark. Let's face the facts.
There's a whole new thing. Yeah. It's,
it's literally a new thing in the world.
We had to create, I create a name for it.
Milk. Why did I create that name?
What else are you going to call?
It doesn't make sense to call it anything
else because there's not anything else.
It just is more,
that's what it is now.
Okay. I got four kids. We know I have
four kids. I spend time with kids.
I see kids all the time.
We got kids Jujitsu programs at my gym.
What do kids need? Kids need fuel. What
do kids get fed? They get fed crap. Why?
Because there's, there's
sugar in everything. There's
high fructose corn syrup,
Corn Syrup and everything.
There's just garbage.
So with my own kids,
what do I want to feed them?
I want to feed them something that's
good. We made warrior kid milk. Why?
Because kids need good food. Eat. We're,
we're putting kids on the warrior path.
I get letters every single day from
kids all over the world. New Zealand,
Australia, Europe, America, for sure.
Kids that are seven years old that are
nine years old, that are 11 years old,
that are 14 years old. And they're
on the path. They're doing pull ups,
they're doing Jujitsu, they're sending
pictures of their Jujitsu tournament.
They're drawing pictures of their metal
that they got for Jujitsu. You know,
there's kids that are on the warrior
kid path. What are they eating?
Are they eating junk? Sometimes they're
eating junk. Not because they want to,
but that's because what's,
that's what's in their fridge.
So had to solve that problem.
So we made warrior kid milk again.
What was equivalent to functionality.
The function was they need protein,
they need vitamins,
any probiotics,
functional part side by side
with that had to taste good.
Yeah. Had to taste good. And what
do we end up with? Warrior kid milk,
chocolate and strawberry.
It's freaking delicious.
Both of them.
They're so good. They're so
tasty. It's ridiculous. So
that's where your kid milk that's
available from origin main.com.
We're going to try and get
that one out to the masses.
Every kid needs or your kid walk instead
of drinking some sugar fold crap of
fillers, we're going to give you real
food going to make you stronger or soda.
Yeah man. I used to, uh, we never had
thought of growing up in my house,
but I used to go to my friend's
house name is Eric Masters.
He's a pilot from the air
force, by the way. Um,
so I go to his house and they'd have, so
he didn't, he didn't, wasn't pounding.
So it all the time is a
superior athlete. Oh, this guy.
But they had cylinder kind of above
the thing. Wait. So when I was a kid,
we didn't even relate. Like soda wasn't
bad for you. We just were like, oh,
this is just, this is just how like,
oh, we just jumped clear. I'm thirsty.
I'm going to drink a coke and mentos or
your Fridays to drink. Joke about that.
Like when you were a kid, like, oh,
I haven't drinken anything all day.
I'm really thirsty. Give me a coke.
Yeah, you just drank it. Exactly right.
And that's the, you didn't know that
there was 36 grams of corn syrup in there.
It's a, yeah, good job. Thinking back,
I'm like, Dang, that is a crazy, crazy.
What could you imagine?
And you only weighed 48 pounds.
It wasn't like, it wasn't like you're
a 225 pound grown man. I'm like,
I am right now. I could probably put
down a coke and it wouldn't character,
but you're,
you're nine years old here.
Get some of that wrong. Some
grape crush pineapple. So many.
I cut you off and do and, and Mr Masters
snow. Yeah, but no, that was that.
That's the point where you're going,
it's just that, that's just how, Oh yeah,
grab a soda after school,
whatever.
They'd sell sodas for 50 cents after
our school. You go in the thing,
you buy the soda, whatever, Soda Machine,
whatever. What if it was Marketo? Oh,
way better.
Way Better.
Cause it tastes just as good if actually
it tastes better than soda because on
for sure undeniable and your,
yeah, that'd be just be way better.
So there you go.
Where your kids Moke Moke for the adults.
And then the other funny thing was I
had all the people send in pictures of
their kids drinking before
we had warrior kid mortgage.
The kids were just straight up going
down the milk, train themselves.
Little Kid's two years old,
three years old, four years old,
little kids drinking milk.
I would get the warrior kid mock
a little less protein. Yeah.
Tasty as can be vitamins,
probiotics.
Just good to go. Way to go.
100%. Yeah, totally good to go.
We're going to change the world with
that one. Going to make it strong again.
Also if you want to represent, we
got some shirts for you, go to Jocko,
store.com that's where you can
get this Lind equals freedom.
A shirt with Jockos head on it that
I made with the word good written.
You also get a shirt with echos
head on it that Jocko made,
which have been now captured in
the wild. People representing. Yes.
Then that made me feel really,
really good. Really? Oh,
so you kind of got off on that. That was
like really cool. Like Oh, I got fans
there.
Of course there's that.
Put it this way for someone
to represent that hardcore,
don't wear that shirt because it's a cool
design. I like it. And then you know,
for them that was a little,
everyone seemed really handle compliment
my direction because I designed it.
Yeah. Everyone seem real happy with
them saying the whole group, you know,
there's some layers on that shirt. Yeah.
Massive multiple layers nonetheless.
Some cool stuff on there. We've
got some hoodies on there. Yeah.
If you want to represent,
go to [inaudible] dot com some good
stuff on there for everybody, by the way.
Yeah, and also subscribe to the
podcast, this podcast for sure.
Itunes, wherever you get podcasts, you
know that also the warrior kid podcast.
Take a listen to it all ages. Take a
listen to it. Definitely kids. Dave Burke,
he's saying he just got that the warrior
kid podcast on repeat. Yeah, guilty,
but he's got the, he's got the warrior
kid podcast on repeat for his kids.
I talked to so many people when we're at
roll call monster, they're like, yeah,
we're, we're going. We just got
it. 24 seven kids in the car.
We listen to warrior kid podcasts.
The lessons that you want to teach your
kid that your kid doesn't really want to
hear from you because you're their mom,
you're their dad.
They don't want to hear it from you. They
want to hear it from Uncle Jake. Yeah.
They want to hear it from Uncle Jake and
I would go so far as to say don't even
one of the, you know, you
said you can't just say, oh,
I'm going to take extreme
ownership of that. Yeah.
What you can do with your
kids is turned round.
When you're in the car and say you see
Uncle Jake saying the same thing I told
you. Yeah, you know, don't
do that. Don't get, don't,
don't discredit uncle Jake and
you're not really discrediting him,
but what you're doing is you're
bringing your, you're forming a team,
right? You're forming a
team. It's us against you.
And when Uncle Jake's talking to the kid,
they're on the same teeth and team.
Uncle Jake is in the game with the kids,
the kids,
you have a natural
friction with your parents.
If you take uncle Jake side strongly,
now you're on uncle channel.
It's you against your kids against,
you don't want that. You should almost
play reverse psychology and be like, well,
you know, it's a little extreme for
uncle Jake to want to work out that much.
And your kid be like, well, I think we
should probably listen to Uncle Jake Dad.
Maybe. Maybe we should get
a pull up bar. By the way,
get a pull up bar for your kids.
Just get a pull up bar form you.
It doesn't cost much.
It costs 12 bucks.
You just need a piece of pipe and you
just hang it somewhere for your kids so
they can do pull, pull ups are important
for children. Yeah. Straight up.
There's some fact about no kid that can
do a pull up is obese in the whole world.
You can't be obese and do a pull
up as a kid thing. That's good.
So let's do some pull ups.
Dig It. Yeah. Yeah. I feel like a good
way to for the don't don't be like,
I'm going to put this on in your
listen. Oh yeah, don't do that. Yeah.
You want the kids you want, it's like
when you go through military bootcamp,
the drill,
the drill instructors are real mean cause
they want you to form a gang against
them. That's part of the psychologies.
They want it to be us against them.
So we form up into a platoon and we're
against this guy and then in the end it
all comes together.
Same thing we're going here.
We you don't you want to let Uncle Jake
be part of their team and you just man
of stuff. Uncle Jake says, man, he
seems like a pretty intense guy. Oh,
and actually uncle Jake isn't that
intense on the warrior could podcast? No,
he's telling stories about being a kid.
Yeah.
He's answering questions
about being a kid.
Yeah. I guess it's soft or not
softer, but like he's not as,
he's more intense than the book
for sure. He's more intense than the both
of the trash. Yeah. Waking Up. Yeah. Yeah,
yeah, yeah. So yeah, sure. There you go.
Also the officer gets
your warrior kid soap,
which Irish oaks rants.
Aiden's up there making soap on his
farm so that you can stay clean.
13 year old businessman getting after it.
Youtube,
we are stepping up youtube videos
confirmed. Confirmed, confirmed.
You may have seen some of them. Little
shorter. A little bit more tight.
Yeah, right and tight. Yeah,
we like that. So go to youtube,
subscribe to that and you can see echoes.
Legit.
Longer videos to ACO has skills.
This is a known fact.
Psychological warfare little album with
tracks to help you get through those
moments. A weakness. There's a new
one being made. We're working on it.
If he got any recommendations or any
suggestions or anything you need from
psychological warfare,
some moment of weakness that you have.
We got a request for shopping an
impulsive shopper. When it put up,
we're going to put a
damper on that straight up.
Just shut that down curve
that other things smoking.
We're going to shut that down. Yeah. So
if you've got any suggestions for that,
then you can make that happen. That's
available anywhere you can buy mp3s. Yeah,
very helpful. 100% success rate. Also,
speaking of moments, a weakness, like
if you don't want to go to the gym,
get stuff, Jim stuff, workout
equipment for your house.
This is where you get them on [inaudible]
Dot com get kettle bells rings,
battle ropes. You can get a uh,
a mason, a club. Do that Bro.
You get a good workout anyway.
Makes it way easier to stay on
the path went cause let's face it,
driving to the gym is not that cool.
And if you're feeling lazy or you're
time is pressuring like time constraints,
but you stay home,
get a workout
hard one too. That's where I get mine.
This Trump. Yeah, on it.com/jocko.
That's a spot to go.
100% also Jocko white tea.
That's,
it was like almost second was going to
have some mutek kicking like a white dude
took them. Well there's the dichotomy
in that too. Sure. It tastes good.
We know that it's tasting good as
part of the functionality I get in.
But like white tea kind of sounds
kind of light and like Dane seem sane.
And then you would read
black coffee. No, no, no.
Black coffee. Get some
pump. I was telling life,
I've never had a sip of
coffee in my whole life.
I thought you said you
didn't like the taste. Okay.
Well I should have clarified that.
You don't like this.
I didn't even like the smell
puts my lips were the alright.
Hey Man, fair enough. I dig
it. Um, Jocko white tea.
My wife's mom. A Brit.
Sure. Like my wife's a Brit.
My wife's mom is even more British.
Right.
Cause it was just an old toy that she
gets what she drinks. Cause you know,
you know British people,
they don't even play around with tea.
They don't even play around with t
deal part of the part of the life.
Guess what kind of tissue drinks
Jokowi's yeah, so obviously she did that.
We're sending shipments of Jocko white
tea to England. So she believes it. The,
the, the, the damn world.
Global home of tea.
Yeah there were having to ship it because
you bought your thing was always the
cold, the ice tea? No half the warranty.
So you oh you mean as far as like
before you made Jocko white tea you,
I'd always see you drinking the
cold one most. Most of the time.
Most of the time I prefer cold cause
most of the time I'm in a situation where
I'm hot and I need to cool down.
Sometimes I'm in a situation where I'm
cool and I need to warm up and when he
wants to sell them,
when you cold you want to be cozy.
But I mean I'm saying Brits, they don't
dig the cold Ice Tea. That's why. Well,
you know what's nice is like
before you have to talk a lot.
I'm sure you can drink
white tea for the throat,
relax the throat and yet at the same
time you're getting a little caffeine hit
her
getting a little caffeine.
He hit her with some antioxidants and
not to mention if there's any vehicles
where you need to pick up,
you got an 8,000 pound dead lift so you're
good to go guarantee whatever we need.
Yeah it's good. I stopped the
Yoav on the other day and he was,
he posted something on Instagram.
He had a chick filet hitter.
So those of you that are wondering about
my head or reference. Yes. Theo von.
Thank you.
You have brought that word
into my vocabulary and I
had a little Jocko white tea
hit her.
I also have been using the term to
describe one scoop of Moloch and we just,
that's just a one.
It just a one scoop hitter.
Good cause cause two scoops legitimately
fills you up. You don't want to eat
a meal. Yeah. No you don't want it.
You ate like a little decent meal
but you still want something,
a dessert to two scoops in.
You're just, that's too much.
Too much. You have that little one scoop
hitter, easy money and you're good to go.
Good to go.
And if you tried the strawberry strawberry
kids more cause ridiculously tasty.
You're on to something on that check
and some books.
Got Some books.
I got quite a few books
actually weigh the warrior kid.
Mark's mission already talked
about that a little bit.
You want your kids on the path to
him. Pullups studying, memorizing,
getting smarter, getting
better. This is not,
this is not, hey, I think this will
happen. This is at this point. Same thing.
I know this will happen.
Your kids will want a pull up bar.
Your kids will want to do Jujitsu.
Your kids will want to study for school,
study for school.
What kid wants to study for school?
Wore your kids warrior kid.
The first book is called
way of the warrior kid.
The second book is called March
mission. Learn about life. Next book,
discipline equals freedom field manual.
I forgot to say this recently.
If you want the audio version of that,
it's on Itunes,
mp3s, whatever, Amazon play,
Google music, whatever. It's,
it's on all those. Yep, and that will,
that's where you get the audio version.
I recommend the book is not normal.
It's not a normal book.
So get that book. Read a page a
day. Read a page a day for a year.
See what that does to your life.
I'll get, make an assessment.
You live, your life will get better.
Is that a bold statement? Maybe,
but let me tell you. Give
it a try. Give it a try.
Extreme ownership.
Interestingly,
extreme ownership number five on the
Wall Street Journal Bestseller list.
It just wasn't a number one
New York Times best seller.
That list rotates or whatever.
Wall Street Journal number five on that.
Number 13 on Amazon.
Most read books of all books on Amazon.
There's millions of books
on there in the world.
It's number 13 we got so extreme
ownership leadership book experiences from
combat applied to your
business and your life today.
The followup to that book,
that dichotomy of leadership also in
New York Times bestseller number 19 on
Amazon of all books read.
That's crazy. Number One,
Wall Street Journal bestseller
in business right now.
Why is this?
Because of you all supporting,
so thank you for supporting those books
and the feedback has been awesome on
both books and definitely appreciate
that feedback and then coming soon,
Mikey and the dragons, it's coming
out on Jocko publishing. Like I,
like I said, if we can make
looms, we can weave material,
we can print some books and
that's what we're doing.
It means it's us against the big dogs,
against the big publishing companies,
so need a little bit. It
gets them. For this one,
I'm going to try and crush him. Why?
Because that's what we do over here.
Hey, story of a little boy that scared
of everything and Lou learns through the
reading of a story inside that
story of how another little boy,
a little prince overcomes his fears,
how to face his dragons because of
course we all have dragons to fight
Mike in the dragons.
It's available for preorder right now
on Amazon comes out middle of November,
echelon,
front leadership consultancy.
We will help your team solve whatever
problems that they have through
leadership, no matter what that
problem is. It's a leadership problem.
It's me, Leif Babin, JP l, Dave Burke,
Flynn Cochran, Mike Cirelli and Mike Bama.
Email us info@echelonfront.com or check
out the website if you need that kind of
help at your business.
I already talked about the monster.
It's been sold out
the next muster's oh seven oh eight
we're looking at Denver and Chicago.
So you're on notice to set that up.
And of course he f Overwatch
connecting special operations leaders.
Okay.
And combat aviation leaders,
experienced leaders, tested leaders,
combat proven leaders with companies
in the civilian sector that need
experienced proven leaders.
Go to e F overwatched.com
to get in that game.
And if you want to roll with us virtually,
you can find us on the inner
webs on Twitter, on Instagram,
and on batch fishing.
Echo is at echo.
Charles and I am at Jocko Willink.
And thanks to everyone for listening,
especially our military police,
law enforcement, firefighters,
paramedics, EMT, yes,
border patrol,
correctional officers,
and all first responders.
Thanks for making this podcast and our
way of life possible by keeping us safe
from evil and misfortune of the
world and to every one else.
When you face those hardships
and challenges that are
coming your way and they
are coming your way,
don't get pushed back on your heels.
Don't ask yourself,
why me?
Ask yourself what am I
going to do about it?
And then
go get after it.
Until next time,
this is echo and Jocko out.